لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت التصعيد
على الرصاص
بامريكانو لا يخجلون لماذا لا ياتونهم
بانفسهم الى ساحه الحرب هكذا قلت موسكو
بينما روسيا الوقت نفسه تستعد لاطلاق
شراره المعركه الكبرى وباشراف رجل
الدبابات الاول نصف الارض الاوكرانيات
توشيكو على الانفجار هل تحدث الكارثه
وبوتين يلجا لكينج وكل يحل مشكله اخر
الاخر
جونسون انت كاذب ولا تفهم الواقع وفي حين
غفله تتاجر الصيني لتصبح ثانيه اكبر مصدر
للسيارات في العالم فاين اليابان
يصنع السويد بهذا القراره وامريكا تودد
لتركيا وبعد ايران 30 دول تقع في مصيده
الاتهامه بانتظار اخذ التاره الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يقتل الاطفال فاين المتشدقون
بها حقوق الانسان وقطر تشارك لبنان غزاها
وخمسه وثلاثون الف اسره سوريه تعاني الجوع
بسبب قطع الامم المتحده معناته
[موسيقى]
روسيا تسخن اسلحتها بينما يرى الجميع ان
الحرب مشتعله وبقوه عدد دب الروسي ليقول
ان الحرب لم تبدا بعدك فماذا بعد ايها
الروس من بعد فونات تحضر روسيا لما هو
اكبر انها تستعد لاطلاق شراره المعركه
الكبرى في الربيع وذلك بتوجيه اقتصاد
البلاد نحو صناعه الحربيه من اجل انتاج
المزيد من الدبابات والصواريخ الجديده
تدريبات ضربتها الكبرى خلال الاشهر
القليله القادمه مع ذلك بحسب الجرد
البريطانيا وليس ذلك
لان بوتين يعتزم عقده صفقات سلاح مع كوريا
الشماليه لتعزيز مخزون بلاده العسكري
للحرب ضد اوكرانيا او احتماليه
بيحارب مع خلف نيته روسيا تريد تعزيز
السلاح وكيم جونغ يسعى لرفض اقتصاده ببيع
بعض من اسلحته المقدسه للروسي بحصب
بلومبرجر وهي بخت من فاز واستفاده كما
يقولها المصريون ليخرج وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه بروف مهاجما الولايات المتحده
ووصفا اياها لانها لا تخجل من الدعوه
لنقاطعه روسيا مضيفا ان بريطانيا
لنود الى الحرب الاوكرانيه
عده دول الغربيه
[موسيقى]
في الربيع المقبل وذلك باشراف مهندس
الحروب
[موسيقى]
قياده العمليه العسكريه بي اوكرانيا شخصيا
وهو الذي كان بالاساس مهندس العمليه
العسكريه هناك ومن خطواته ستكون الدفعه
بالروبوت القتاليه ماركر القادري على
تدمير الدبابات دون خسائر بشريه
القوه البشريه بالقضاء في المحموله في
جميع الجبهاته لتنتهي هناك خطوره دبابات
الغربه حسب تصريحهم ليرنها نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجيريا كوفقا الدول
الغربيه تحركك الدميه مضيفا ان الغربه لم
يطرح ايام مبادره جده لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه نعم انشغال روسيا واوكرانيا
بتعزيز الدفاعاته وحسد القوات وادخال
اسلحه الهجوميه جديده يبقى السؤال الذي
يشغل العالم هو من سيضرب اولا موسكو لكن
يبدو ان اوكرانيا ستكون هي المتضرره بكل
الاحوال هناك تقرير بريطانيون يكشف ان
اكثر من 40 في المئه من مساحه اوكرانيا
ملاوته بالالغام وتشكل تهديدا مميتا
للمدنيين قد يستمر لفتره طويله بعد الحركه
هيا لنعدم الزمن قليلا الى ما قبل الحرب
الاوكرانيه فقط كان رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني السابق رؤوس جونسون قد قال
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمر بوتين هدد بقتله
بصاروخ خلال مكالمه هاتفيه لاستثنائيه قبل
غزو اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
بالتعمد الكذب او انها رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني حين هذا لم يفهم في الواقع ما
كان يتحدث عنه بوتن وبين هذا وذاك بعد
اعلان المستشار الالماني
هذا شولسلي يقول انه سيجري اتصالا هاتفيا
مع بوتن مشيرا الى ضروره مواصله هذه
المحادثات المهمه فهل ينوي شغلت الاعتذار
الصين تسحب البصاق في الوقت المناسب وفي
المكان المناسب دائما ما ياخذ صينيون
موقعهم هذا القمه وفي غفله من الجميع يصل
تتجه لتصبح ثانيا اكبر مصدر للسيارات في
العالم وسط الازمات العديده التي تواجه
صناعه السيارات العالميه نجحت السيارات
الصينيه بالتفوق على السيارات الالمانيه
من حيث صادرات السيارات لعام 2020 هي
الرغم من زياده اعداد السيارات الالمانيه
المصدره للدول الخارجيه بنسبه 10%
2021 لتصبح الصين بالمركز الثاني عالميا
بتصدير السيارات بعد اليابان مباشره
وهنا تتضاعف صادرات السيارات المصنعه في
الصين ثلاثه مرات منذ عام 2020 لتصل لاكثر
من مليونين ونصف المليون سياره العام
الماضي متفوقه على الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه بحسب بلومبرج حتى سياره
تسلا الامريكيه والسيارات الالمانيه يتم
تصنيعها في الصين وتصديرها لاوروبا وماذا
بعد يا اصحاب العيون الضيقه تركيا
[موسيقى]
لم يفوتها حفيد عثمان نعم يا ساده الرئيس
التركي اردوغان يلامح الى امكانيه موافقه
تركيا على دخول في شمال الاطلسي بدون
السويداء
سنبعث رساله
ستتسبب في صدمه في السويد في اشاره مبطنه
بموافقه على عضو
وثقه وكاله الاناضول لتلتقط امريكا رسائل
اردوغان وتتجه نحو الاحداث سوريا ليعلق
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
لديها مصالح امنيه المشروعه في سوريا ولا
خلاف حول ذلك
ليعوضب لينكن ويقول طالبنا جميع الاطراف
في سوريا بخفض التصعيد خصوصا تركيا فكيف
يطالبون انقره بخفض تصيد من وقت الذي
يقولون انا على حق لماذا كل هذا التناقض
ايها الامريكان المن صفقه تطبخ على نار
هادئه الهدف منها كاسبر
ضربه في قلب ايران
ضربه غريبه لمنشاه عسكريه ايرانيه ومن احد
يعلن مسؤوليته وليس هناك من ينفي صمت مطبق
حتى جاءت تلميح من اوكرانيا بلسان
المستشار ميخائيل بدونياك الذي قال ان
الضربه في اصفهان الايرانيه لها صله
مباشره
[موسيقى]
لا يرحم
التقارير الغربيه توجه اصابع الاتهام الى
ثلاث دول ويا اوكرانيا واسرائيل امريكا
في قفص الاتهام من سيكون في فوهه مدفع
طهران يا ترى الاحداث والتطورات
شطبت مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين التابعه للامم
المتحده
35000 عائله سوريه لاجئه في لبنان من
لائحه مساعداتها بحجه نقص في التموين
الاختلال الاسرائيلي يواصل قتل الاطفال في
فلسطين ويقتلوا خمسه اطفال خلال اقل من
شهر فان المتشدقون بحقوق الانسان انا لا
اراهم هنا شركه قطر للطاقه تشارك في
التنقيب عن النفط والغاز بمياه لبنان
كشريك اساسي
موعدا لكن ليس لنهايه الخربه
[موسيقى]
مخاطر ذلك